I guess start off do you find children
to be as terrorizing as they are in this
film they certainly can be they can also
be sweet and loving and yeah especially
when they want something what are the
best ways to keep kids in line
theoretically dangle the carrot whatever
it is they want negotiations yeah but
it's tough when they're little cuz um I
mean they've so dort you know babies
like forget it they just I'm such a mush
but um toddlers are tough sort of like
like it's like they're really drunk
maybe but they can't speak English you
know it's a very irrational baby are you
trying to deal with as parents just
don't think people he did that you were
like no don't don't do that stop uh when
they went after the good guy at the
school and and bade him up and yeah but
they he deserved it I mean they ran out
of the car though and they left the kids
in the car that was that was a big how
was your I had already gotten out and
you were supposed to stay in the car and
you came running out anyway and
interfere with Daddy duty stuff so oh
that's my bad but you didn't say what
about our kids we can repent because I
was already in the heat at a moment
oh yeah right Nick that gang of
redheaded kids yeah cuz he was really
scary like it yeah probably I don't know
protect you America you didn't say
anything you'd say anything it's how it
was like on set just the second the
cameras are off it's over wait and talk
you've both done a lot of sort of family
sort of comedy is what is it about this
sort of heartwarming genre that that
appeals to you why do you well this was
such a no-brainer I mean I I would have
been nervous to do this without Sean to
be honest historian inspired by him so
it was so authentic and it was about
just not kind of screwing it up too much
what about for you mark
to be able to make movies that
especially these movies don't come
around that often where you have wildly
entertaining for both children and
adults but also has such an important
message
you know I like to mix it up after this
it was like I was excited to kind of go
back and do something different but
what's it like when your own family sees
you as a dad on screen is that is that
strange or surreal um no they enjoyed it
mm-hmm yeah they're actually all excited
to go back to the movie in a week and a
half two weeks Oh
you